okay now let's talk about Donald Trump's
press secretary Kelly Mack and Annie
defending Donald Trump's white power
tweet this is just completely
unconscionable yesterday I told you that
Donald Trump put out a tweet over the
weekend which included a video in which
one of his supporters yells white power
at anti-trump protesters Donald Trump's
exact tweet was quote thank you to the
great people of the villages the radical
left do nothing Democrats will fall in
the fall corrupt Jo is shot see you soon
here is the video that Trump shared with
that comment you'll notice that about
eight seconds in you hear this guy yell
white power twice so first earlier
yesterday on Fox and Friends Donald
Trump's press secretary Kayleigh Mac and
Annie said Trump didn't hear the white
power part now that's weird because the
white power part is eight seconds into
the video but that's what Kayleigh Mac
and Annie said yesterday on Fox and
Friends
oh yeah the president tweeted out that
tweet yesterday and took it down if you
played it it was a guy saying white
supremacy it was another woman or white
you know white power white power and
then the woman was yelling obscenities
because she doesn't like the president
at some of the guys that were in the
parade down at the villages what's the
president's response did he know what he
was tweeting when he did he accidentally
tweet that so the president did not hear
that phrase in that portion of the video
and when it was signaled to him that
this was in there he took that tweet
down now there's already a lie there
reports are not that Trump immediately
took it down as soon as he found out
about the white power thing the reports
are that aides spent three hours trying
to convince Trump to take the video down
despite making it clear up front that
there's a guy saying white power in the
video so Kayle saying oh as soon as
Trump found out about white power he
took it right down that's a lie three
hours is not immediately taking it down
but then she says hey you know he does
stay
and with his supporters at the villages
even the guy who said white power even
if I guess he doesn't stand by the white
power comment take a look at that but he
made very clear to me that he stands
with the people of the villages are
great seniors men and women in the
villages who support this president he
stands for them and his point in
tweeting out that video was to stand
with his supporters who are oftentimes
demonized so we didn't hear that portion
he took it down but he does stand with
the men and women of the villages we are
truly living in some of the stupidest
times that I can remember and I guess by
saying Trump still supports his
supporters but not white power she's
saying she still supports the guy who
yelled white power just not yelling
white power I guess I mean it's
completely incoherent that was on Fox
later yesterday Kaley did a press
briefing and during the press briefing
the question was asked did Trump even
watch the video because the white power
part it's not like two minutes in it's
eight seconds in and Kaley says yes he
watched it but he didn't hear anybody
say white power Thank You Kelly I wanted
to go back to the tweets of President
today I'm afraid
power and the
and that when it was single to him that
that was there
so the president retweet other people's
tweets and be
we did not hear that particular phrase
when he tweeted out the video and he did
and he did not hear that particular
phrase Trump watched the video but
didn't hear the shouts of white power
eight seconds in I guess that's the
story they're going for so I my message
with all of this listen you all know
Trump lies all the time in his
administration lies all the time
my message to you is how stupid does he
think his followers are if these are the
explanations they give Oh Trump wasn't
briefed on Russian bounties we now have
three credible reports that he was
briefed as long as a year more than a
year ago
15 months ago Oh Trump didn't hear
anybody yell white power it's eight
seconds in did Trump watch the video
yeah he watched the video
he just didn't hear anybody yell white
power the disdain that they have for
their supporters is stunning if they
believe their supporters will fall for
the stuff and what's sad is a lot of the
supporters do and that is something that
you know when when when we go and we
think about voting in November we have
to remember that even if we're not
falling for these obvious lies from
Trump supporters from Trump meant to
trick his supporters the supporters are
falling for it we're going to talk about
some more of those lies later about
protests and coronavirus cases and the
like make sure you're following the
david pakman show on instagram at david
pakman show follow me on Instagram at
David Pakman for continued coverage of
my very safe socially distant vacation
here in Martha's Vineyard we'll take a
quick break and be back with so much
more right after this